The better one is before that when it's like he's clearly trying
to dox both me and Queenman. He's made multiple attempts. Okay,
multiple attempts. Basically, because the with the TTRO, what
they didn't do was explain why how the behavior has changed since
the suit has been filed. Oh, crazy. It's almost like when this
guy's doxing and threatening to get people and saying, "I want
these people." It's almost like that scares people. Putting a
spotlight on his actions, which is the actual reason he's upset.
is that valid criticism is being platformed. He has no response
to it whatsoever and so he is lying and cheating in any way he
can to get around it. Right. These weird Destiny comments cuz
this is just some odd dude. It's just odd panel. Uh kind of a
panel. I guess we'll see. We'll see what happens precisely. All
right. So, okay. Desessie went live and tried to explain why
it's okay to attempt to dox and direct violence towards me by
openly lying to his audience. I'm shocked he's willing to do
these. Sorry. I'm shocked he's willing to go to these extents
without providing any evidence whatsoever that I support any
of the issues he claims exist. Yes. Yes. Oh, wait. Hold on. Holding.
Holding. Holding. Holding on. Holding on. I'm holding. Holding.
Still holding. Okay. Good. We're good, Kenny. Thank you. Thank
you for holding. We'll do the N3DS stuff after this. We have
a LSF mod update after this. We'll check that out. But we're
going to cover this real quick. This won't This shouldn't take
too long. Okay. But Destiny, it's just Destiny like lying like
straight up lying again again again lying again. I saw a video
where everyone losing their mind that Destiny threatened to somebody
cuz I have like three threatened to now he didn't threaten to
kill me. He said he wants somebody well one he said he would
kill me. So maybe that maybe you consider that a threat but like
I guess technically you could argue it's not precisely a threat.
And then and then he said he wished somebody would kill me. And
then he said, "Why would I dox somebody? Why would I try to dox
somebody? What do I want them?" And he has tried to dox me. So
like there's three different vectors here of him wanting me dead,
right? Multiple interview a lot of people including him in it.
We discuss a lot. Just watch this. This is him responding to
basically this clip and my my stuff. So apparently this guy wants
me dead, which by the way, this is just flat out true. Allegations,
people accusing you of doxing, right? because you're referring
to Kiwi Farms. Uh Ryan did this with Anna and then um JT Stalk
is doing this. Quan is sort of doing this where there's DMs about
you saying like, "Hey, I wish this person has this person been
doxed yet." So this would have been late February. I I need to
correct that from yesterday. I thought this was the off the record
call. No, this would be like late This would be late February
probably is when this call happened. Yeah, I um for Anna that's
for just like Queen. I'd kill him if I could. I choke the house
and do it. Um, but not for Anna. No people like you're saying.
Yeah. No. What the like why would I even want to do that? Like
what am I want? What? Like that's I do want somebody to logistical
though or laugh or Mr. Girl or Quman. Those people can all die.
It's taken so long. Wow. Wow. So he wants somebody to kill us.
Uh he said he wouldn't dox Anna because he doesn't want her to
get then he tried to dox me and Queen. And then he also said
oh wait what was the first one with Anna sort of doing this for
these? about you saying like, "Hey, I wish this." Oh, yeah. He
said he would choke us if he could. Right. So, three different
three different ways. Yeah. So, like let's ask a serious question.
Okay. Okay. Say you're streaming like a streaming. Okay. A night
like tonight. All right. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. It's 10:00 p.m. Okay.
You look out your window. Destiny pulls up. What do you do? Uh,
I have no idea. I don't have I'm in Canada. I don't have fire.
[__] What do you mean you have no idea? No. No [__]
idea. No [__] idea. But we'll watch him uh respond
to this today. I guess apparently he's uh he's going to respond
to this today. He's apparently got a reason that he could do
all of this. Now, of course, this reason is going to fly in the
face of everything he's ever said about any of these topics ever.
But I'm sure he's going to go ahead everyone losing their mind
that threatened to somebody cuz I have like three communities
on that are obsessively upote down voting. Oh my. Why would that
matter? Why would that matter? What is that relevant to? How
does how does he get this question of him threatening violence
or encouraging violence? And then his first response is, "Well,
there are three communities on LSF just like uploading, downloading
my shit." Imagine the victim mindset that goes into that. Okay,
imagine the victim mindset that goes in. Wait, you're a Destiny
fan. Why is he so obsessed with LSF? Is there a reason or I have
no idea where I It's like way bigger than it now. I mean, yeah,
I have no idea. just saw a video where everyone losing their
mind that Destiny threatened to somebody cuz I have like three
communities on that are obsessively upote down voting all my
I just I don't know why where is that where what does that have
to do with anything what does it have to do trying to like advocate
for violence on people um people are I think I don't even remember
this phone call this was like months ago but somebody basically
asked me I think Willie Mack asked me something like oh like
how do you feel about uh these people whatever and I was like
if you're somebody that is actively engaged in a community that
is like spam linking revenge in front of me revenge Uh, docs
of me, docs of my girlfriend, revenge. Like, if you're doing
Okay, so should we go through that? Maybe we have to go a little
slower there. Hold on. Maybe we have to go a little bit slower.
Spam linking. Revenge of me. Revenge spam linking. Revenge of
me. So, not just one link or something, which I don't know if
that's happened. I don't think so.
But apparently it's more than one link, just spam linking. So,
you think if it was spam linking that he would have some proof
of that, right? He's spam. We're spam linking. That's he says
the violence wanting these people dead, wishing harm on them,
advocating for violence against them is justified because they
spam link revenge in front of me. So that's that doesn't happen
to my community. That's totally against Discord TS2s. If that
did happen, my community would be gone, right? Obviously. So
he is trying to attach us to Kiwi Farms. That's what he's trying
to do. He's trying to say this is like Kiwi Farms is the same
thing, which is people get their posts removed if they link to
Kiwi Farms. People get if they link images from Kiwi Farms, it
gets removed. The only thing I ever do with Kiwi Farm stuff is
basically they'll go and get all of his little spurouts in DGG
chat and they'll format it with the questions and the have his
response, right? So, I like to go get those from Kiwi Farms because
it just saves me so much time from having to go get those myself,
right? So, he's trying to get revenge form spam, which doesn't
happen in my Discord ever. It's never happened in my Discord.
And he's trying to apply that to him wishing death on me. So,
I don't know how that applies, but that's interesting. That's
the first one. revenge of me. Revenge uh docs of me doc. So linking
docs of him again apparently linking docs of him. I don't believe
that's ever happened. Um if it would happen or if it did happen
it would like people would be getting banned, right? Because
we do not want that happening on the discord. That's against
to obviously that'd be very bad. Uh that was totally against
our that's totally against our policy. I don't I haven't seen
any instances of it. Um those people would be banned. Those people
would be kicked out. I mean at least like probably a month or
something, right? um depending on what their intent was. If they
were just like, "Here's Docs of Destiny. Boom. Yeah, perma. Bye."
Right. Obviously, so it's never happened. He's just totally making
this up. Which is why, by the way, just like with Vos, how he
used to call Vos out. He'll never post evidence of this. He'll
never post clips of this. He'll never do anything to show that
this actually happened. All he'll ever do is say it happened
and then he will want you to believe him. Right. Uh I don't agree
with him, but his argument is you let Lav Yeah, but Lav didn't
do those things. And if Lav did those things, she'd be banned.
Yeah, I I understand that he wants to just do the webbing thing,
but the webbing thing with Lav Lav's conduct is she's only culpable
for the conduct in my community. I don't ban for cross server
[__] ever. Docs of my girlfriend. Oh, docs of his
girlfriend. Docs of his girlfriend. Never happened either. Never
once happened in a million years. Never will happen. Did not
happen. Did not happen. Did not happen. He's just totally making
that up again. And by the way, I think his whole thing with the
uh his whole thing with the Kelly Jean thing, right? His whole
thing with the Kelly Jean thing was, "Oh, uh, Kelly's talking,
so I'm going to like dox these people." Kelly's not around right
now. She's not She's not talking any of that. Didn't call her
a cheap. Yeah, Kelly talks, but Kelly didn't do that. And I'm
not Kelly. And he's not saying he wants to kill Kelly, right?
Where's his message that he wants to kill Kelly? Where is his
anything he's saying that he wants to kill Kelly or wishes harm
on her or wants violence enacted against her? He's talking about
me. I'm getting blamed for like eight degrees of separation actions,
which is totally insane considering when when people were blaming
his community for Keit, right? He lost his mind. He lost his
mind. You can't say Kelly cuz Kelly will actually pull up and
him up, but he's just he's just lying. And I mean, it's fine.
He can just lie all he likes of me. Revenge uh docks of me docks
of my girlfriend. Revenge. So that has never happened in my community.
Nothing around me. Nothing around Queenman. Nothing around Mr.
Girl. Nothing around Lav as far as I know. And even if it was
Lav is somewhere else like entirely. So nothing around me, nothing
to do with me. He just totally made that up. Porn like if you're
And then he says revenge on like if you're doing revenge for
my So I think he cuts himself off there because what I believe
happened is is that there was port of his girlfriend put on some
message board and he's trying to web that message board to my
community. Okay. But that would be like uh legally uh attainable
that she had published on the internet right now. He probably
stopped this line of attack because he realized that he actually
did that exact thing to Kelly Gene provably in his DGG chat that
he was linking her Only Fans content in his DGG chat. That he
has done these things precisely, right? He has doxed people.
He has posted what he is now referring to as revenge in his DG
chat. I've never done that, but he wants me. So, he's done all
of these things. He's attached me to Kiwi Farm somehow in his
schizophrenic mind. Okay. I have nothing to do with them at all.
But he's attached me somehow. And now he's going to attack me
as if the that happens on Kiwi Farms is my fault. Yeah, he's
a disgusting freak. He is a disgusting freak. I just I don't
I don't understand where any of this comes from. And I don't
understand how a community that claims to have any critical thinking
ability can swallow this disgusting deformed being shoved down
their throat in the form of like this idea, right? when they
spent years hearing about how Vosch was doing this to Destiny
and it was the worst thing you could do with no evidence. You
just say these things are happening, right? With like zero evidence.
It's baffling. How in the how is it happening? How do we get
this [__] going on?
I super don't give a what happens to you if anything. So, if
you're doing all this [__] I super don't give a [__]
But I didn't do any of that. I've done none of those things.
Destiny's girlfriend quite literally thanked me for not harassing
her and not uh basically every time Kelly went to say something
rude, I'd say, "That's [__] up. Don't do that. That's
[__] up. Don't do that." She literally thanked me
for it. I don't understand where where he gets this from. She
didn't say I did that. She's never had a problem with me. And
he is now advocating violence against me and trying to dox me
based on whose opinion? His like schizophrenic idea of what could
be happening. That's it. That's all. Dox of me. Docks of my girlfriend.
Like if you're doing all this [__] I super don't
give a I've done none of those things ever.
What happens to you if any? Sure. Yeah. Quan did none of those
things. Mr. Girl did none of those things. He just makes all
of this [__] up. Docs of me. Docs of my girlfriend.
Revenge of my like if you're doing all don't defend. I'm not
Wait. I'm I'm pointing out that he's lying. It requires an explanation.
I'm just pointing out that he's lying obviously. And every DJ
should understand that you need to go and find evidence of these
things. You need to have evidence of these things. That you can't
just take his word for it. that he's just going to lie because
he's in the wrong because he's trying to deflect from the fact
that he's a terrible human being. That he has no concern for
other human beings whatsoever. That he that he leaked uh non-consensually
pornography of Pixie, Molina, Stashia, other people, okay? That
he leaked the identity that was protected above anything else
in Lauren's life. She protected the identity of her son and Destiny
leaked that as well. But so, by the way, it's not just on a level.
It's not just a sickness. It is a personal, moral, romantic,
all relationships encompassing sickness that he doesn't consider
other people human beings. He just he just leaks anything about
them with no concern for them or their privacy or anything else
going on. Right, Lauren? Lauren has always protected the identity
of her son. She's never posted his picture online. Never posted
a picture of his face. Never posted his name. Tried to keep him
protected. Who ruined that? Who sent that all down the tubes?
That was Destiny. Apparently to the woman he quote unquote loves,
Lawrence. Lauren as a kid. Yeah, Lauren Southern has a kid and
Lauren Southern's kid's name is on the internet now because of
Destiny. So, I would love to ask Counterpoints at some point.
Actually, it would be very interesting to hear from Counterpoints
on this. Hey, Counterpoints. Uh, you're you're friends with Lauren,
right? Should she have expected this? Should she have actually
known that just by getting in a relationship with Destiny, she'd
actually be exposing her son's identity to the entire internet?
Should she have been aware of that? Actually, she was kind of
asking for her son's identity to be exposed, right? Like, she
kind of deserved it, right? I think she kind of deserved it actually
now that I'm now that we're really thinking about it. Wait, what?
What is this? Whose search history is this? Oh, is this what
the [__] Oh, O is uh leaking his uh O is leaking
his [__] Search DG chat bal narcissism definition.
How to connect Discord account to Twitter. Does every YouTube
username have an app before it? Oh, interesting. Sorry, that's
a little funny. That's a little funny. I thought it was a Destiny.
Anyway, so how far do we get through this? I haven't even gotten
halfway more than halfway through it. What happens to you if
anything or whatever? I think that was basically the gist of
the question. And these guys who are all kind of like sliding
um they have no audiences and people like the fact that I'm even
saying this now is going to be the next like 15 hours of streams
for all these people. We got um Yeah. I mean, I'm going to talk
about it for at least as long as he does. Dude, it's a I'm a
drama streamer. It's a It's not drama season right now. Okay.
I'm enjoying I'm enjoying every time he decides he's going to
go make a complete ass of himself. I'm enjoying it because every
time it makes all of the people who haven't come out and said
like this guy's a total piece of [__] makes everybody
around him who hasn't come out and said that look even worse.
Every single time. Every single time. He doesn't he doesn't care.
I know he doesn't care but he's just stomps on Erodite's credibility,
right? like every single time when she's like actually I think
he's a really good person and he just comes out and he stomps
he absolutely curb stomps not so erodite into the ground right
every time he does [__] like this every time he tries
to defend his action or sorry his actions even without leaking
the son's name why did he send all those personal DMs to a third
party uh because he does not consider other people as like equal
and equivalent consciouses conscious consciousnesses consciousnesses
He just he just doesn't think of them that way. It's like him
and him alone. That's it. Because they're like so desperately
clinging on to anything that they can talk about relating to
me. They've like uh latched on to this is like I'm trying to
get them or something. It's just likeing what? How many times
did he advocate for violence against me? Like I listen I think
Destiny's too much of a to do anything ever. He would never ever
attempt to do anything in these situations. He is way too much
of a made to attempt anything. So realistically, I don't think
he's going to do anything. But I do think it's a little concerning
when he starts going, "Oh, I wish somebody would kill these.
I wish someone would take care of these guys and he's got a cult-like
audience." That's what gets a little concerning, right? He's
way too much of a to do anything himself, but like it's a little
concerning. Oh, also when I kind of defended him a little bit
and was like, "Oh, don't forget guys, I think this was like off
the record. He might not have known this was public." This was
absolutely on the record 100%. This was entirely on the record.
So he knew that this was going to be published and he did these
call to violencees these calls to violence anyway. And so basically
the only thing that could possibly that in a DJ's mind if you
believe that oh if somebody docks you then you have the right
to call for violence call for them to be if they believe that
well I didn't do that. So that's all invalid anyway. I'm still
working on my Destiny part two video where I interview a lot
of people including him in it. We discuss a lot of allegations
people accusing you of doxing right because you're referring
to Kiwi Farms. Uh Ryan did this with Anna and then um Jay Stalk
is doing this. Quan is sort of doing this where there's DMs about
you saying like, "Hey, I wish this person has this person been
doxed yet." Yeah, I um for Anna that's for just I'd kill him
if I could. I'd choke the house into it. Um but not for Anna.
No, he wouldn't. He's completely made. Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. I forgot. I forgot. He's just like his hero,
guys.
You guys remember? Do we Do any of us remember the Mike from
PA stuff? Oh my goodness. Do you remember how cringe this was?
This is who Destiny is. This all the time in high school and
as an adult, you have to at some point respond, but keeping it
to say about character and not physically is great. Wait, Douggee
Chan. Okay, explain the uh the threats the calls to violence.
Explain the explicit calls to violence. I mean, listen, all I'm
saying is on site, you know, we all have different All I'm saying
is J and Queen, it's on site, bro. It's on site. I show up and
get you. It's our sight. Ways that we react, you know. So, I
would like him to come to TwitchCon and we'll see what
I have enough. I could afford all the lawyers. This depends.
It's not like This is literally who Destiny is now. He's just
Mike from PA. That's who he is. Wait, did this justing change
channels? God damn it. Hold on. Yes. One more thing. from FL.
This
song, you better not go to
noitch. If I see you, you better know it's my I'mma beat your
ass on God, [__] Better know my name. When you see
me rolling up, better know I'm gay. Yeah, [__] I
do my thing. When I see you rolling up, cuz you a lame.
Please don't doubt my aim. When you see me rolling up, better
know I bring the pain. I'm that [__] from PA. You
know it from the fame. When I see you rolling up, I start shooting.
Bang bang
bang. I think Mike was trying to be serious while Desi was obviously
saying it as a joke. No matter. He just defended it again. Why?
How can people possibly be like he's joking? He literally just
defended it again today. He literally doubled down and said,
"No, I should be able to say this." What do you mean? Why do
you mean he's
joking? Double down on the same thing. You think you could say
that to an audience? You think you think you could joke about
people to an audience full of crazy people? Yes. Oh, sorry. Sorry.
You You could, but you would be insanely reckless doing it, right?
But he didn't he didn't say, "Oh, this is just a joke. I didn't
mean it." He literally just doubled down. Hardcore double down.
But that's okay. I I'm not shocked that Listen, if any if any,
you know, cognitive victims want to hop in the
discord.gg/jstdlk, there are any cognitive victims here who think
they're the guy who's finally going to be able to defend Destiny.
I would love for you to hop in the Discord. That's the best content
that exists. Okay? When these cognitive victims hop in the Discord
and, you know, totally spill their spaghetti all over the floor,
there's nothing I love more. But I know most of you are too scared
to do it. So it's it's I understand. I understand. I understand.
Such as the life of a cognitive victim. Okay. I I mean that might
be it. Oh, right, right, right. So this is uh Destiny is doing
a combination of things. Okay. So he's doing the simulacrim thing
where he the only thing that gets shown on my screen or from
my stream. It's never like it's never my opinions any long form
me speaking. It's only his representation of me, right? He's
just built up an entirely different representation of me to his
community, right? That's all he's ever done. But then there's
one other thing is the webbing thing. And I I love I love this
clip because it says exactly what he's doing, right? He's trying
to web my community into Kiwi Farms, which is totally facious,
totally incorrect, but he's going to attempt it anymore. I call
this a webbing when I see it happen online. What people want
to do sometimes is I don't actually have to know a thing a single
thing about you or attack anything you say if I can just tie
you into like negative already. So like if I know that you're
Red Pill and I know that Sneo's red pill, I don't know anything
about you, but I know that you're on this podcast. So I can call
you red pill and take you down just like I would these two guys
without ever knowing a single thing about you. And a lot of people
do that. Um I call this webbing. When I say how right? I don't
have to know a single thing about you. I don't have to know a
single thing about you. I can just do whatever I want online.
What people want to do sometimes is I don't actually have to
know a thing a single thing about you or attack anything you
say if I can just tie you into like negative already. So, like
if I know that you're Red Pill and I know that Sneo I would just
love Destiny to address the fact that he is the reason that Lauren
Southern um despite all of her best efforts has her son's identity
leaked on the internet. Like respond to that that you and your
complete lack of concern for the people you claim to care about
is the reason that Lauren Southern's all of her work years and
years of the most meticulous careful shaping of everything that
ever goes out online. All of her pictures with this kid's face
edited out, all thrown down the drain because you had to leak
her son's name to a 19-year-old Discord kitten who you didn't
know, couldn't identify in real life, can't find now, right?
And obviously was potentially a minor when you started talking.
It was Red Pill. I don't know anything about you, but I know
that you're on this podcast, so I can call you Red Pill and take
you down just like I would these two guys without ever knowing
a single thing about you. And a lot of people do that. Doesn't
need to know anything about my community. Doesn't need any of
that, right? Doesn't need to know anything about my community.
All he has to do is say, "Oh, it's like Kiwi Farms." Leave alone
the fact, okay, all the Kiwi Farms talking points. Leave alone
the fact that obviously he used Kiwi Farms to source his entire
Keels manifesto. Leave alone the fact that he offered to float
Kiwi Farms while Keles was attacking them. Leave alone the fact
that he posted on Kiwi Farms despite it already hosting revenge
of him. Right. Wasn't a moral problem then. Wasn't Oh, nobody
cares about male victims then. It was, oh, I don't really care.
I'm going to post on Kiwi Farms anyway. Right. Offered to financially
float it. Yeah, sorry. I I did three. Four, but there's three.
That was in the ring room. Wait, where are the other 14 hours
and 50 minutes of coverage of that clip? Other though other clip
though. Wait, what do you mean? What do you mean? Oh, sure. He's
talking about the 15 hour. Um the um Destiny said he said he
didn't do 15. Sure. Maybe between all these different streams,
but uh yeah, obviously he directed people towards Anavar's Kiwi
Farms, directed people towards Keville's Kiwi Farms, directed
people towards Labs Kiwi Farms. He's used it as a weapon against
other people, right? He just has no ground to actually get pissed
about. Um, I call this webbing. When I see it happen online,
what people want to do sometimes is I don't actually have to
know a thing a single thing about you or attack anything you
say. If I can just tie you into like negative already. So, like
if I know that you're Red Pill and I know that Sneo is red pill.
I don't know anything about you, but I know that you're on this
podcast, so I can call you Red Pill and take you down. Yeah.
I don't I just don't know what to like I don't know what else
to say. Like I just I post and everybody's like, "Dude, he's
only he's only like trying to get people to kill you. He's only
like arguing people should be trying to kill you. Like why do
you keep Why are you so obsessed with him? Why are you so obsessed
with this guy? Why are you so obsessed? You're going to deny
you agreed with Ryan Beard with using Kiwi Farms for a content
nuke against Destiny? No. Oh my god, these people are actually
embarrassing. The whole point of Kiwi Farms here is that if you're
just taking information, if I'm just getting quotes from Destiny
that I could get from Russell Search, but I'm getting them nicely
formatted from Kiwi Farms, I don't have any problem with it.
One second. I need to send a message. Oh [__] Oh,
never mind. I can't send a message. Yo, get this guy in the waiting
room. Don't like pierce the veil. Oh, he left. Oh, if that guy
wants to join. Yeah, that guy can join. Yeah, hold on. Who's
Pierce the veil? Yeah, complete. He's His name is Really Jean.
This
guy, he might be a troll.
Yeah, he's just a troll, but let's go. Really Gene, you're on
the stream. What's up, buddy?
How's it going? Sorry. Yeah. Um, so the only thing I disagree
with you on is like when you talk about Destiny, like I don't
understand the difference between like him before and him now
where like he surely was always wishing for like people to die.
I don't know if he like was openly calling for it in the same
way like I hope somebody kills this guy. I don't I don't think
he's I don't know if he's said that. Maybe he has. Maybe he said
I hope somebody kills this person. I want I think he said wait
hold on. I think he said I think he said I want somebody to kill
this person. Right. Yeah. like the the DOS kid or like even like
the way he talked about. Well, that's him threatening on his
own. Sure, the DOS kid is uh it it is maybe a little comparable
to the DOS kid except I'm not attacking his money. I'm just attacking
his reputation, right? I'm attacking his actions. I'm putting
a spotlight on his actions, which is the actual reason he's upset
is that valid criticism is being platformed. He has no response
to it whatsoever. And so, he is lying and cheating in any way
he can to get around it. Right. ing you of doxing. Here we'll
we'll see her to dox her is what you're saying. Yeah. No. What
the [__] Like why would I even want to do that? Like
I do want somebody to logistical though or laugh. Yeah. I do
want somebody to this person. Yeah. Yeah. The the the only thing
like I think of is like I'm pretty sure that's the way he like
talked about like even like probably not someone like Hassan
but people like that like political opponents back in the day.
Like I don't know if maybe maybe but like I think there was a
whole shift right where he tried to become more like mainstream.
He tried to become like more reasonable. People thought he'd
like mellowed out a lot, right? I think that was the impression
and I didn't watch him back then. So I can't speak to that. Like
I didn't watch him back that long ago. Okay, fair enough. Fair
enough. Yeah. Yeah. That was my only disagreement was like cuz
like I've seen him like threaten death on like so many different
people. Like I don't know if he's like just reverting back to
it or it's like a new thing. Yeah. I don't even I mean it's threatening
death. I guess he said he showed up at my house, but it's also
like wishing like like calling for violence. I want somebody
to do this, right? In no uncertain terms. I want somebody to
do this. And then instead of saying like I was joking or I was
just heated or something, he says no. Uh actually here are all
the justifications for why this person should be right. Uh kind
Yeah. Yeah. Kind of. I think what the the real difference is
the fact that, you know, he's like sharing around people's doxes
and saying the same thing. It's probably the most insane bit
about it. But yeah, I say like I I remember him talking about
like different rad random people used to like debate back in
the day and like saying the exact same thing. It's like I literally
hope someone like you know like same to the Trump guy but like
not that bad. Like he used to do that a lot but yeah. Oh maybe.
Yeah. I've never seen like those clips. I was aware of the DOS
kid thing, but it's like I understand the maybe the DOS kid thing
in some to some extent, but it's like that's them uh like stealing
from you or something or likeing with you in a way that's like
uh invalid, like society invalid, like they're breaking the law
basically, right? What I'm doing is I'm repeatedly covering his
horrible conduct that makes him look like a horrible person and
he has no rational or logical response to any of the points I
make and so he will continue to point out things that haven't
happened because he has no actual response to give. Yeah. No,
I agree with that. I would love to see if like anybody had like
a rational response to give. I just I have not seen anyone who
comes on with like any sort of rational logical argument whatsoever.
Um the best somebody can ever do is basically this is like either
saying one, yeah, he is as bad a person as you want. He's basically
Ethan Ralph and I like him anyway, which I'm like, okay, that's
fine if you just for the content or whatever. Or they'll say
something along the lines of like, oh well, he's always been
like a really bad person. And it's like, okay, well, I mean,
I didn't see it that way, but if you're just going to say that
like, yeah, he is somebody who's going to threaten to like he's
actually a danger to people. Um, he's always been a danger to
people. It's always been dangerous to like allow him to have
a voice. Okay, that's fine. Yeah, I I mean, that's kind of what
I was saying.
Just kind of this for me would go a long way towards, okay, he's
referring to him openly calling for violence on people in some
other clip and he is defending openly calling for violence. That
is on his platform right there. Right. That's finally on YouTube.
He is now advocating openly going for violence against people
and he's lying to do it. So I I think like that's very interesting
to me that this is like an open an open advocation for something
he's called for in another place which is hey I want somebody
to kill this guy and he's saying no no I'm totally justified
in saying I want somebody to kill this guy. Absolutely. Um I
mean yeah like as I say like like you know I can see it now like
especially you talking about where it's like oh it's a call to
violence and it's like obviously like a creator that I watch
you know as opposed to like a political opponent but like I guarantee
if you go through like the DGG logs he has called for the death
of like so many people you know I mean especially in the early
days of YouTube you know what I mean you know I mean it's like
I'm kind of realizing it as well like I I'm not I'm not defending
him. I'm sort of just bringing it to you that like he has called
for death calls for death for a lot of people. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Like I'm not defending him, but Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Sure. How is
it? I would love to see I didn't get a chance to see it, but
I'd love to see how Darius uh defends the like open calls to
violence that he like doubles down on. I I think it's really
funny seeing a lot of people who used to argue with Darius
um like break away from that camp. They like used to try to make
arguments. The arguments used to be like, "No, Destiny isn't
going to dox anybody. He's not going to try to dox anybody. He's
just looking for like addresses cuz he wants to file a defamation
case. And then Destiny immediately doxes people. And now they're
like, you know what? Actually, he's not trying to threaten anybody.
He's not trying to hurt anybody. He's just like uh he's he's
just like angry and upset. And then Destiny like doubles down
and says, "No, no, no. I'm totally justified in calling for them
to die. I'm totally justified."
It's uh it's pretty funny. Uh so Darius, Erdite, anybody who
argued with Darius, they're just getting totally made fools of
every time this guy doubles down on being a Sorry. Go ahead.
Yeah, true. No, I was going to say it's like, do many people
even like defend that part of the SNA anymore?
All right. Well, I'll let you go anyway. Good content. I'll keep
watching. GG's. Okay. All right. GG's. We'll talk to you later.
Bye-bye. Okay. Bye. God, I'm just I'm looking. There's somebody
who can defend this conduct, right? There's somebody who would
go like, "This is based." I just I would love to see anybody.
There's just no one. It's too bad. It You hate to see it. You
really hate to see it. I would. Can you Uptown Lupo? Are you
gonna hop on stream and do it right now? You're gonna you're
gonna come on stream and defend it right now. Let's go. Get on
the stream. Also, I'm going to play this one more time. I'm losing
my mind that he threatened to somebody cuz I have like three
communities on that are obsessively up down voting. Oh my. Um,
people are I think I don't even remember this phone call. This
was like months ago, but somebody basically asked me I think
Willie Mack asked me something like, "Oh, like how do you feel
about uh these people whatever?" Like if you're somebody that
is actively engaged in a community that is like spam linking
revenge in front of me, revenge uh docs of me, docs of my girlfriend,
revenge, like if you're doing all this, I super don't give a
what happens to you if anything or whatever. I think that was
basically the gist of the question and these guys who are all
kind of like sliding
um they have no audiences and people like the fact that I'm even
saying this now is going to be the next like 15 hours of streams
for all these people. I will say though, it is a little funny.
Okay. It's a little funny that in my head I'm like I keep doubling
down in the same direction where it's like Destiny's too much
of a [__] to like dox me and I'm like dox me then.
Dox me then loser. Do it from your own account. And then he did
and I'm like kill me then loser. Kill me with your own gun. It's
like a well I should probably watch outside of my door or something.
I I listen a little bit. I'm like dude there's no way it would
totally him over. It would make him look so unhinged. uh he tried
to dox me, but it uh it would make him look so unhinged to everybody
if he like did these things. And then I'm like, "Oh, wait." Like
Erdite doesn't make a public post. Pisco doesn't make a public
post. Nobody makes a public post about this conduct. Nobody cares.
And I'm like, "Oh, actually, he can just he could kill me. He
actually could kill me. Like he he could absolutely kill me and
nobody would just be like, "That's pretty bad, I guess, man.
I think maybe the police should do something about that. That's
kind of bad." No. No. She would be You only care. You're only
asking me about JTO's death because I'm a woman around Destiny.
You're a misogynist. It's like at some point I'm like some of
these people will like stand on on just like morality and be
like, "Oh, actually this guy's gone way beyond the pale." And
like it's not just something where I'm like not really going
to deal with them. I'm actually going to say like this person
was a bad person. I regret spending time around them. I regret
getting close to them. I regret being anywhere near them. Actually,
they're a really bad person. They're like an awfuling human being.
I wish I wish anybody had made that post. I don't think anyone
other than essentially all relevant has has given that sentiment
out online which is just sad to me. Odishara chat. What is this?
This Odishara guy is insanely mentally ill. He's he's like insanely
mentally ill. He made up an entire um he made up an entire fanfiction
about how somebody sent a letter and they said they're from Jtock's
community. Apparently, he got a letter in the mail that said
they're from Jtock's community and they're going to like and
that like they think he's like going to people around him or
something in the mail. So, of my like couple hundred person community
that apparently that happened. And then I'm like, "Hey, could
you like send me the the letter?" And he's like, "No, I had to
throw it out." And it's like, "Oh, so you you just blatantly
made that up. You're just like insanely mentally ill and made
that up out of nothing." like like like beyond insanely mentally
ill. Beyond insanely mentally ill. Like it's so and and like
he said this like the mental illness is thinking that you can
tell that story and not have everybody laugh at you. Everybody
around you is laughing at you. Response to Shara J's kind of
cooking you but he's just like insanely he's like beyond the
pale gone. That guy's a nurse, right? I mean that's very unfortunate
for those people is all I could say when the waiting becomes
the I mean cognitively yeah new court docs up on the website.
Wait, there's new court docs.
What? But is there so I saw there's a transcript of their session
or whatever but it wasn't available yet. Oh, is it avail? Oh,
it's not unopposed motion for extension of time to file response.
Reply answer to to 36 order on motion for preliminary injunction.
Plaintist motion for temporary restraining order. Motion for
preliminary injunction by Steven Banell. Hold on a second. So,
they're looking for Oh, the transcript of the status conference
is included. Oh, we should read this. Yes, let's read this. How
long is it? How long is it? How long? Oh, it's not even that
long. Let's go. Oh, yes. Hold on. We just need to make sure that
uh we just need to make sure that it's not too crazy. Okay, so
the transcript got filed. And so wait, wait, wait. Let's see
what this is precisely here. What is it precisely here? I'm not
totally sure yet. It is. I don't like Zoom hearings. I just need
to make sure that I don't have uh some addresses or some names
in here that are ones we shouldn't have. I don't think there's
addresses or anything either. Okay. All right. So, they posted
they posted the transcript. We can go over that. Odishara equals
the male aranina. Yeah, pretty much. Pretty much the guy is just
beyond. It's like it's actually terrifying how mentally ill he
is. Oh, Pixie filed for with a new attorney. So, there's a transcript
of the status conference and then the extension. Okay, so basically
Destiny asked for a the ability to file this. Okay, let's check
this out. Let's start reading here. Okay, I'm I'm already in
my judges robe based. Hold on. I got to move Kenny a little bit.
Kenny's in the wrong spot. Kenny's in the wrong place for this.
What? I'm always in the right place. Oh, let's see here. Uh,
let's see.
Okay.
Um, all right. This is this is the extension. And then as a part
of this, there's also the transcript of the TTRO hearing. Okay.
So, let's check it out. Kick is breaking. Unfortunate. Why do
you hate him? I'm confused. Beyond the death threats and the
the attempted doxing, uh, I don't know. Difficult to say. Beyond
the the the uh the complete lack of concern for any other human
being, beyond the crimes, beyond all of his malfeasants, him
absolutely disrespecting the consent of every woman around him,
despite the fact that he purports to be like some kind of male
feministish figure, some blue pill like, oh, male women deserve
rights, women deserve respect. Yeah, beyond those things, I don't
know. I don't know. Not much beyond those like five or six points,
actually. Defendant Steven Banell. Banell files the unopposed
motion. So this is asking for more time to file an opposition
to the preliminary restraining order. Uh files the unopposed
motion for extension of time and requests a twoe extension to
file his opposition to plaintiff Jane do's motion for preliminary
injunction ECF number 21 and in support thereof states as follows.
On April 3rd 2025 plaintiff filed a motion for temporary restraining
order preliminary and preliminary injunction ECF number 21. On
April 4th, the Honorable Jacqueline Becca conducted a status
conference to adjust the timing of the plaintiff's motion. At
that hearing, Judge Becker noted that because the case has been
pending since February, there did not appear to be any exigent
circumstances, nor a need for emergency relief. So, this is actually
what I was saying to you guys, that it was basically the TTRO
was only rejected because, hey, actually, with the the TTRO and
the the preliminary injunction are the same thing. One version
just says, I need you to grant it now before really considering
anything. We have we have like a 30-minute meeting. you can't
look at anything else cuz there's such a emergency that we'll
be if you don't grant it right and the preliminary injunction
is saying we can do the same thing I want the same relief but
we can wait a little bit okay now with the preliminary injunction
that's as far as I know there's still a hearing for it so at
that hearing she said there appeared not to be an emergency which
is fair hey the case has been pending for like a month and a
half now uh probably if there was like a massive emergency this
would have been filed now there's arguments against that that
by the time like February 18th rolled
Maybe the the conduct hadn't really appeared yet, right? But
okay, that's fine. If she just says, "No, it's like been a while.
This is fine." Dude, is Kek really this? Okay. Anyway, ruling
that the plaintiff's application for a temporary restraining
order was stale. Judge Becca denied the Turo and indicated that
the court would refer for the surviving motion for preliminary
injunction to the honorable Edwin G. Torres to set briefing schedule
and ultimately issue a report on recommend and recommendation.
On April 7th, Magistrate Judge Torres issued a paperless order
requiring Banell to file his response in opposition to the motion
for preliminary injunction by Friday, April 11th, that is three
days from now. Following receipt of the court's paperless order
on April 7th, the undersigned council wrote to the plaintiff's
council in an effort to meet and confer regarding the scope of
the prelim for the of the motion for preliminary injunction and
to request plaintiff's consent to an extension of the opposition
deadline. By email dated April 8th, 2025, plaintiffs council
indicated they do not oppose the motion for extension because
the parties are going to discuss possible stipulations to certain
relief which may avoid the need for a preliminary injunction
hearing. A true and correct copy of the meet and confer correspondence
from April 7th and 8th is attached hereto as exhibit B. So basically
the Pixie lawyer said, "Okay, yeah, we can do an extension because
it'll give us time to talk about how you could follow this preliminary
injunction. Like you could give us this relief without having
it ordered by the court." Chad's so delayed. Yeah, Chad will
come back, guys. Give it 2 minutes. It'll be It'll be right back
here. Hold on. I need to send another message to Kick. Hold on.
It's really been a persistent and long longstanding issue. It's
actually
crippling the site as a primary streaming platform. Okay. Boom.
There it is. Sent message to kick. Hold on. Do we have DMs here?
Oh, right, right, right, right. Oh, actually, I haven't once
tonight, guys. Guys, we need some subs. We need some dodos. We
haven't shilled to extend the time at all tonight. Okay, guys.
If you want to donate to extend the stream, okay, exclamation
point donate in the chat, there are two links. There's the kick.
Oh, hold on. That's definitely not going to work. Exclamation
point, donate. You're cooked.
Been happening nightly for two to three weeks now. KCIP is cooked.
This isn't a minor occurrence. It actually happens on a nightly
basis. They they respond, "Hello there. Our platform is experiencing
some issues at the moment. Please be assured that we are actively
working to resolve this issue and we appreciate your patience
during this period. It's like, okay, but now I've gotten this
message like eight times from you that everything's kick is totally
again. And it's like, okay, should I like do I need to just start
streaming on Twitch? Is that what I have to do? I don't want
to. I really don't want to. I would love to just stream on my
on my own platform, okay, on kick. But I dude, people can't chat.
It like cripples the entire It's such I see some people's chats
coming through a little bit, but Jesus Christ. We're like doing
a whole segment here and it's all Okay, finally the exclamation
point donate went through. God, now I can lock one of these donation
links. So, there is the uh the kickbot and the stream labs, guys.
Go through Kickbot or Streamlabs to donate. Every dollar goes
towards extra time on the stream. You can gift subs. Okay, you
can give subs. You can sub yourself. It's a 955 split when you
sub on kick. Kick appears to be back. Let's go. All right, it's
a 955 split when you sub on kick. Okay, I appreciate every dollar
you guys give. We are six subs away from another hour on the
stream. Uh, also don't forget there's the Patreon.
patreon.com/jstlk. This is your hub for all extra content, okay?
All extra content, couple different tiers. The support means
the world to me, okay? Any support is really appreciated. I love
you guys. All right, I love you guys. This is awesome. Is Callum
here? Is Aquilla here? Does Aquilla come here anymore? I think
Aquilla left. I don't think Aquilla comes here anymore. How do
we close this? Hold on. I don't know if uh Hold on. Slash user
Aquilla. Yeah, not since January 23rd.
You don't slot. Thank you for the five gifted. Let'sing go. Let's
go. Let's go. Let's go. All right. So, where were we here? They
basically they agreed. They say maybe we can uh negotiate a couple
different things. Uh, Barbadoo, thank you for the gifted sub.
That is another hour on the stream. Thank you. Thank you. Thank
you. Based based base, base. Okay. Probably the last donut for
the week. That is awesome. Thank you, Solid Sloth, for all of
your help. You are you're carrying the stream solo. Following
receipt of the course paper. Yes, they're extending so they can
continue to look through this. In light of the agreement among
council, Banell respectfully requests a two-week extension of
the current April 11th, 2025 opposition deadline to afford the
party sufficient time to discuss a possible stipulation and potentially
avoid motion practice altogether. To the extent parties are unable
to reach a stipulation, the brief extension will permit Banell
adequate time to submit thorough opposition papers. Federal rule
of civil procedure 6B allows for an extension of time where,
as here, a party shows good. So, this is basically just them
asking for this.
Uh, I will just be your pay.
Trash man donated $10. Let's go. Put a slot machine in the corner
and the stream will work. Appreciate you letting me come on stream
even though we never disagree that much. No problem. 10 trash
man. XXX 10 Trash Man. Thank you very much for coming on the
stream and yeah, maybe put a steak logo down there and it'll
work. Let's go. Okay. Oh, don't don't go down. Okay. So, it's
basically just asking for an extension. Now, the big one, the
big cool one, okay, is the transcript. So, apparently the judges
yelled at Pixie side for lying about everything. And uh yeah,
what did what did Destiny have to say about this? He was like,
"The judge yelled at them for this when realistically, I believe
the way he represents it is very interesting to me." Okay, hold
on. Judge, this guy chats a lot now. What the Am I not seeing
this correctly? When was this? Hold on. Where am I seeing this?
Oh, they did get chastised a bit yesterday for waiting so long
to file the TTRO. Okay. Them waiting so long to file it was a
joke. She's already made everything so public. It's just stupid.
I think Destiny literally is too understand that the same relief
is in both the TTRO and the preliminary injunction and that the
relief is not insane and the judge didn't deem it insane. He's
like, "Oh, it's so stupid that they've tried this. The whole
thing's been denied." And he actually didn't understand that
it was only partially denied because they were just like, "Oh,
actually, if this was like a, you know, within one week needs
to be solved thing, it would have been done before." Fat Destiny
donated
$12.79. Thanks for the content. Uh, thank you very much, Fat
Destiny. Let's go. We are
$8 away. Like two subs away for another hour on the stream, guys.
Oh, I didn't add that first hour either. So, now we get to We
get to read all of it. Scammer. Scammer. We get to read all of
it. And let me uh let me go in. What am I doing? Oh, I need to
reset the timer. Timer. Timer. Timer. Hold on. Add up a timer.
Boom. There it is. Okay. Call to the order of court. Uh, call
to the order of court at 4:37 p.m. Courtroom deputy. Case number
25 CV 2020 20757. Becca do versus Benell. Council, please state
your appearances for the record. Jesus, what just happened? Hey
yo, hacker man,
what? Please state your appearances or your who you are. uh stating
starting with the plaintiffs that are present uh present in the
courtroom. Defendant present in the courtroom and then parties
on Zoom. Miss Schlump, good afternoon, your honor. Joan Peter
Schlump on behalf of the plaintiff. M uh Mr. Garcia Perez. Good
afternoon, your honor. Carlos Perez on behalf of the plaintiff.
Good afternoon, your honor. Robert Rapsk on uh for the defendant.
Good afternoon, your honor. Andrew Breler. Uh thank you for allowing
me to appear remotely. Also for the defendant, Patino. Patricia
Patino, behalf of the defendant. Are you from the Miami office?
I am. I'm just I'm not just not in Miami at the moment. I don't
like Zoom hearings. Everybody can be seated. I only allow counsel
that are out of town. I just don't want to give anybody the misimpression
that about when I allow Zoom hearings. You may be seated or you
can be seated council. Oh, this guy's smart. The Breler guy is
smart. He knew she didn't like Zoom meetings. So, he said thank
you for letting me call in through Zoom. Okay. Uh, thank you,
your honor. So, this case has been pending for a number of months.
You looked at me a little, ma'am. Didn't you file it a couple
months ago? February 21st, I believe. Yes. Yes. Correct. It's
April. So, it's been filed. The parties are already met in for
the joint status report that was already filed. I've got a scheduling
order. The defendants have answered. And now, last night, I get
a tier based on facts that don't appear to be from any different
uh any different from the complaint. So, I want to hear just
very briefly. Oh, they didn't do a good job of I thought they
didn't do a very good job of this. So, basically basically because
the with the TTRO, what they didn't do was explain why how the
behavior has changed since the suit has been filed.
I think you can probably go in and show like some of the behavior
that's changed since the suit has been filed or things you haven't
included which are the posting of pixies DMs, the posting of
Cher's DMs, the repeated harassment of people supporting them,
right? Um now you go as far as to say like threatening to kill
people who are covering this stuff from a from any perspective.
Okay. The only person who's going and reading these court documents
each night, uh Destiny wants them apparently. So, the TTRO, but
again, I I do understand that like, hey, the probably if there
was needed a to be a TTRO here, we probably should have filed
it earlier. Well, your honor, I do apologize for the delay in
getting the mo that motion out. There are a number of reasons
why that happened. One, and I hate to go into personal things,
but Mr. Garcia was dealing with a cancer issue and going back
and forth to Texas. I had pneumonia and I was straight out for
more than two weeks. So, we were really set back. There's just
two of us working on this case. And so that significantly delayed
us dumbass lawyers doing reasons which is that we are trying
to gather affidavit from witnesses to bolster our evidence for
the TTRO and get you know witnesses lined up for it. Unfortunately
what we have encountered we have a number of women that have
come forward to us but have then backed out because they're afraid
of retaliation and that's what they've told us and so we are
not able to get these affidavit. We went with what we now have
which is basically we went from 15 potential witnesses providing
evidence down to one witness in addition to the plaintiff. Oh
crazy. It's almost like when this guy's doxing and threatening
to get people saying, "I want these people." It's almost like
that scares people.
Bro, imagine you have a get a get a lawyer, two lawyers,
one has pneumonia.
It's actually so based that you can just threaten everybody and
they'll all leave. They'll just everybody be like, "Oh, this
is too much. This is too much." It's so awesome. Mr. Girl Article
2.0. I mean, technically this time they would have the evidence
from these people and like I have a bunch of evidence so I don't
know. I listen I don't know. I don't know, man. I don't know,
man. I don't know. No way it worked. Oh, it totally works. By
the way, like just so you know, like Far and Jasmine both have
firsthand first party knowledge of Destiny violating the wire
topping laws of Florida, right? They will not testify anywhere.
They don't want anything to do with this. They don't want any
retribution from Destiny. They don't know it's been recorded.
They don't want to [__] around with it. They're both
out. They won't comment on this whatsoever, right? Because they're
afraid of what he'll release about them. Yeah, that's that's
like a lot of people obviously like I don't know. I'm sitting
here. I'm like, dude, if this guy me, he's got to go to jail
then, right? Surely Aerodite will will be turned against him
then. Surely, bro. Read that paragraph. The court cooks them.
That doesn't have to do anything with anything. Jesus Christ.
This is not a class action. You filed on behalf of one woman.
The TR requests that he remove the video of one woman and then
this there's this request with respect to whether or not he is
doing anything to destroy evidence in this case. I don't know
that that's a TTRO. I think this more Ken you can file a motion
with respect to that. None of that sounds like a TTRO to me.
Obviously the medical issue I hope you're doing better. So basically
this is all the TTRO is um although I do think um she's saying
that like you don't need temporary you can like literally just
present your evidence for this which is fair. Thank you. I hope
it's not obviously more than a short delay on the case, but I
don't see the emergency nature of the TTRO. This is again what
I was saying. This seems to me at best a preliminary injunction.
There's nothing that's happening today that wasn't happening
when you filed the suit or even a month before that, right? In
fact, if anything, like the date seems to line up with uh sometime
at the end of this year. So, probably what should have happened
is like they probably should have filed a TTRO for Destiny commenting
on this in the first place because now he has acted so crazy,
so unhinged that a whole bunch of people have basically said,
"You know what? I don't want to comment anymore. And there's
lots of people in my DMs, too, are like, "Yeah, I I'm sorry.
This guy will destroy my life. I'm not doing this. I'm not doing
it." It's amazing. And like, unfortunately, what do you do in
this case? Do you Do you say like, "I'll protect the the the
like these victims?" I don't know. I don't actually know what
you do in these cases is very interesting. Okay. So, she thinks
that it's a preliminary injunction. So, she's like, "Oh, you
could ask for this relief, but like um I'm fine with uh I'm fine
with you asking for the relief, but it's not a tier." I mean,
April, I don't see why the request for a TRO is not stale. I
understand your concerns, your honor, and this is why we didn't
file it as an emergency TTRO. I agree that most of the damage
has already been done, but the issue is that we keep receiving
evidence of destruction of evidence. We are trying to compile
enough evidence to file a motion for spoliation because we are
very concerned with the fact that all evidence is disappearing.
So, we are hoping that to file that very shortly. We're waiting
for a specific piece of evidence that we wanted to bring before
the court. So, yes, I agree with you that this is not an urgent
matter for having a TR immediately, but it is ongoing harm that
we want would like to stop. That's why a preliminary injunction
I think is more appropriate. Yeah. So it's like yeah it's totally
reasonable to ask him to stop deleting evidence to ask him to
stop threatening people to ask him to stop leaking details about
the people he's victimized. That's probably all reasonable but
uh realistically he was doing this when you filed the case. So
without filing a TTRO when the case was filed right like he has
always been this piece of so you should have filed it back then.
So, so my intention was to deny your request for temporary restraining
order, but set a preliminary injunction hearing. You uh and refer
that through to the magistrate judge who has got you. You know,
he doesn't have my trial schedule so he can hear the preliminary
injunction. You will issue a report and recommendation on the
preliminary injunction, which I would hear any objection and
I will rule it uh on it as soon as possible. But it seems to
me that the harm you're sounding, as best I can tell, I might
be wrong, but to the extent that we're really talking about the
spoilation issue, that seems to be more a spoilation than a PI.
But I don't want to get ahead of myself. Oh, so like deleting
evidence actually also probably shouldn't be filed under the
preliminary injunction. It should be you file a motion about
expulliation. We can handle that as a PI and it might not even
be a PI. It might just be an issue in spilation. And I will tell
you that uh even as you've pledged it so far, we'll see what
the defense says, but I got sued for distributing the materials
about a woman and I may have done that with other women. Then
I might say to myself, maybe I shouldn't do that anymore. Let
me delete that. Let me take that back. Let me not do those things
I'm being alleged of doing because I'm maybe these things are
bad and I shouldn't be doing that. There may be one of the the
things that's going on that's not spoilation. I don't know some
of the stuff that's in this motion. I'm not finding on its face
the connection to this case. I assume you will make the argument
to judge Torres and line up how or connect it up how it's connected
to this case because some of it I don't know is a spoilation
issue even right at least how you've played it so far and how
you've argued it so far. So I called you in for the status because
I didn't know if there was something else happening with respect
to the timing for the TTRO. I'm assuming that you've also been
talking to council because we were together for joint scheduling
for the joint scheduling report. Correct. Sorry, your honor.
We were shocked to hear about this, sir. I'm talking to council
for plaintiff. I will get to you.
So, you were definitely together for the joint scheduling report.
Yes. And no, we did not discuss a motion for TTRO during the
joint scheduling session. We just discussed scheduling. Dude,
I don't know if lawyers are just overloaded, but like um like
they're not even very good at making arguments. Like I think
the people on the internet are better at making at least persuasive
arguments. Maybe not logically strong arguments, but like I could
argue why you need a TRO in this and like it's that hey, he seems
to be amping up the rhetoric and now like a bunch of people are
scared, right? And that's happened since we filed the case. That
would be why it's been a little while. And then I guess I don't know
how you explain weeks later. One was dealing with cancer and
one had pneumonia. Let's let's be fair. They were I mean I guess
so. I does that mean like Yeah, I don't know. I think the judge
said beyond the beyond the staleness, she doesn't think there's
a emergency demonstration needed. I'm guessing that probably
they filed both because they just wanted to see if they could
get either one, right? Like basically it's like well we'll file
a TRO as well cuz we're granted that relief under the federal
statute and if not well whatever. Well, so that was one of the
reliefs that we were seeking in the motion. Uh we just was just
that he be ordered to preserve and not delete any further evidence.
So, I don't think that's even subject to the hero. And I'll tell
you why. You have both a preservation letter plus a complaint
plus a scheduling order. If the defendant after having notice
of the suit is destroying evidence, I mean, he's got lawyers
who I am sure are advising him of what he can and can't do. If
I were to find or if Judge Torres were to find as part of a discovery
issue that he destroyed evidence, well, there's all sorts of
remedies that the court would can take to do that. Okay. So,
there's like literally him doing logs of like I have I have destroyed
evidence. The order that we're you're seeking requires him to
do nothing more than he's already required to do because Yeah,
that's what I said. It's like you already have the preservation
order. I don't think like the judge he's already been told by
the court. He's already been told with the full legal authority
of like the fact that this case exists. Like you can't delete
evidence if he's going to it's like telling it's like I'm not
going to order a TTRO saying don't murder people. Yeah, you can't
murder people. Obviously, stop murdering people, right? I don't
need to tell you like you're already ordered not to do that.
You can't destroy evidence after you're on notice of the suit
and the preservation letter has been sent. So if he is in fact
destroying evidence, he can't do that. If he doesn't think it's
destroying evidence for some reason, well, that will play out
either in a motion or explation or maybe in the preliminary injunction.
But to is to issue a temporary restraining order now on some
sort of urgent basis. One, I think it's stale because even that
has been going on for some time. That's not something that you
found out right now and I need to stop it right now. Yeah, exactly.
So the TTRO is basically like, hey, something's happening. We'll
be if you don't grant us this. The case is right. And it's like,
well, if he deleted the evidence and it's already deleted, then
we can just do that in a preliminary injunction. That doesn't
I I don't need to I don't need to enjoin him from some conduct
to prevent him doing it further. Okay. Right. So, I'm going to
deny your motion for TR. I know it was I just said it for status,
but I don't want to have it set the I don't want to have to set
the TRO for Wednesday to tell you that tell you what I'm telling
you now because I don't think I've read your papers. I think
based on your papers TR is stale. But unless I hear an objection
from you, not that your objection would necessarily change my
mind, but I'm going to let you put the objection on the record
if you have one, and I but I will deny your TR and set you send
you to go to Judge Torres to have him set the hearing for the
preliminary injunction. Okay. I mean, this all seems to be pretty
much exactly what we were saying before, right? Yeah, that's
that's it seems very obvious to me. So, I will point out no one
is destroying evidence. I will further point out that we have
we had no meet and confer efforts with plaintiff's counsel about
this. We were stunned to see not only one but two motions and
it looked like for a TRO filed yesterday and I understand that
council did say that they didn't file it as an emergency TTRO
but by its very nature TTRO's are an emergency seeking emergency
relief. We agree with the court's assessment and have no objection
to have this referred to the magistrate for PI hearing. The court
there are two TTRO's but I thought the second one was essentially
amended the first. There wasn't a different recovery, right?
Sure. So administrative assistant [__] up the filing.
So, I'm going to deny 20. It's moot. Uh 20 duplicative and the
preliminary injunction. So, the she's not saying we won't grant
the relief. She's saying that based on this uh there's not something
I need to stop from happening that like that I can fix. It's
not like it's basically like a ti. Imagine a ti is basically
like somebody walks by. You're in a like a court case with somebody
and you are in the middle of the how do I do this? You have like
a big chunk of water, a big barrel of water and it's like basically
they stab a hole into your barrel of water. It's starting to
bleed out water and it's like judge I need you to fix this right
now or else I'm going to like lose I'm going to lose it but my
business will be my case will be right. There's no there's no
case like that for the TTRO. So it's probably not worth it to
file a TRO. Let me just say you know I don't think that there
is I have to check the local rule because I can't set it from
memory. Although I probably should be able to. I don't think
there's an obligation necessarily for them to confer on the TTRO
being said blah blah blah blah blah. I don't think there's a
requirement. Uh that being said, this does strike me as something
that you could talk about and say because even from the evidence
that plaintiff has shown, it seems like the defendant, at least
with these messages to the plaintiff, is suggesting that he would
withdraw the video or try to do the things with the video to
take it out of the public space. That seems like something you
might be able to work out. Maybe not. I don't know. And if there
is an issue of the destruction of evidence, that's something
that emotion expiliation you will have to confer. It seems to
me you should be conferring about this that it makes more sense
and especially if you want a resolution that's quicker and it
uh is to talk about it because you will have to set it uh uh
set it for the PI that there will be a hearing. There will have
to be a written report and recommendation. It will have to come
to me. I think you should pick up the phone and talk. So, it's
basically saying, "Hey, you guys should talk about like actually
agreeing to do these things." I mean, it is a little odd, ma'am.
I will just say if you're sitting talking about the schedule
and everything, clearly you're already working on the TRO. probably
the defendant didn't love to get the TTRO filed like the day
after you were conferring for an hour on schedule. It doesn't
mean you couldn't do it. It's just not great that you didn't.
So basically they're saying like, "Hey, if you were planning
to do the preliminary injunction, you should have talked to the
other people and said like, hey, could you stop doing this?"
There are numerous reasons you might want to do that. Um, so
I I I could see it. It could be some kind of playing things,
right? Like maybe you just want it filed so that it can be covered
publicly. That could be it. Yeah, Marma, dude. But that's what
I said yesterday is it's just saying the TR is not the appropriate
venue for this relief. It's not saying the relief isn't required.
It's not saying the relief is like something they can't ask for.
It's saying that like a TRO there the the purpose of a TTRO is
not going to be required here to get you your relief. That's
it. That's all. Okay. Uh we have had discussions with council
prior to this and they were very not productive. So I did not
think that discussing this matter with them. I mean Mr. Bretler
just said his client is not destroying evidence. We know the
client is destroying evidence. We've seen it. So, it's not just
Hold on. Hold on. When I speak, you have to stop. Sorry. Go ahead.
Yes. Sorry, judge. One, not just because I'm the judge, but two,
because my court reporter only writes down what one person says.
And I promise it's always what I'm saying if there are two people
talking. My point is you have to tell them your client is destroying
evidence. Or my point is you can tell them your client is destroying
evidence. Of course, they're going to tell you that he's not.
I would hope they're going to say that. Now, if they Now, if
you show them evidence of it, they're probably going to say,
"Yeah, he is destroying evidence." They're Oh, sorry. They're
probably not going to say, "Yeah, he's destroying evidence."
But they might talk to their client and come to some agreement
with you about what he can and can't do. Okay? So, you know,
productivity isn't them acquiescing to your allegation, but you
might be able to get some resolution blah blah blah blah blah.
Um, what he can and can't do with his emails and what he can
and can't do with his chats. I mean, there are so many platforms
and things now. I don't even try to keep up with them. Even though
I have a teenager, I think I do try to keep up with them. I don't
because there's something new that comes about every day. Comes
out every day. Okay. So, whatever platforms he is chatting with
people or talking to people on, you know, these things I know
are moving targets, but it's always a productive to talk. And
let me just say one more thing because it's it's day not day
one because you filed in February, but we're really really early
on in this litigation that will be before me for God knows how
long. You need to confer. Understood? Uh you and you need to
confer a lot. I think good lawyers working in good faith can
work out a lot of things and when you can't, that's my job and
I'm happy to hear disputes. I obviously love it. So, she's basically
saying that like, hey, uh, I think I it seems more to me like
she's trying to set a precedent for like if you haven't raised
these uh these problems to co to the opposing council that I
don't want them brought before my court. It sounds mostly like
that's what she's trying to do. She's trying to set a precedent,
right? And say, "Hey, don't bring things before me. Go and talk
to each other. And then when you can't resolve things beyond
between each other, then come talk to me." Yeah. And then when
you can show me you've talked to each other, then I'm not going
to get mad. Uh, so I hear you that these lawyers aren't going
to agree with you probably on much when it comes to the substance,
but it does help to crystallize the issues if you at least talk
to each other. And it's very difficult when there they've been
sitting with you for an hour talking about the schedule. You
never mention the turo and it gets filed. It doesn't help in
terms of lawyers trusting each other to at least bring issues
in good faith. It's a complex case. I understand. You know, it's
a sensitive matter for your client. I understand that. But if
we want to go forward, God, she this judge is aing yapper. Holy.
Keep talking to the defense. Just only bring things Yeah. I'm
tell I'm just trying to tell you to work in good faith and try
to bring things to the court when they've been crystallized and
when they have been vetted by both sides. That's what she's trying
to set is a precedent. She's just saying, "Hey, I don't want
this. I don't want this one-sided. I don't want you to file a
motion that shocks the other people. This isn'ting this isn't
suits. You're not on the USA network." Okay? Talk to the other
people. Let them know what you're trying to do. Okay? Okay. And
then once you've done that, come here. Although it is interesting
that the judge says, "Yeah, I do think that you probably would
have ended up here over deletion of evidence anyway." Okay. All
right. Because in my court schedule, in my trial schedule, it
will be referred to the magistrate judge. I would expect that
by Monday, you know, his chambers will reach out to you by order
or by phone or something or Tuesday or Tuesday maybe to figure
out what those dates are and what the schedule is. All right.
Anything else on behalf of the plaintiff? No, your honor. on
behalf of the defendant. The only thing is, your honor, is I
will absolutely appear in person at future hearings. The only
reason I couldn't is because we only had 18 hours of notice on
this one. Otherwise, I would have been on an airplane. I would
appreciate uh the court's accommodation. Look, I missed it because
I saw Billen and I missed that there was an LA lawyer on it and
I just wanted to have it today because I'm out of the district
Monday and Tuesday. I don't want to have a TR wait till Wednesday.
So, we just jumped on to set a hearing. I know it's Friday afternoon.
It's almost 5:'lock. Sorry, Miami traffic. Friday afternoon,
it's rough. I wasn't trying to punish anybody. I've just had
all hearings all day. And so this is all the space I have for
you. Okay. It's literally just, hey, you guys need to talk to
each other. Uh I don't think that I don't think a TTRO is the
appropriate venue for this. So you can seek the relief. The relief
you're seeking is fine. Um I set it up with the magistrate judge.
Come back tomorrow. Or come back tomorrow. Come back whenever
the magistrate judge is.
Um can you scroll back up to the top? Who had cancer and who
had pneumonia? I just have to see this. Uh both of Pixie's lawyers.
Both of Pixie's lawyers. Holy [__]
Apparently. Yeah. I mean, to be honest, I don't know if they
needed a ti necessarily, but that's fine. Don't Don't Oh, yeah.
Sorry. The reason Destiny said it was denied was it sounds like
she doesn't want him to speak at all about this publicly, and
it's not making sense to me given she's literally crowdfunding
this lawsuit. That's why it was denied. That's not why it was
denied. Actually, we just we just read about why it was denied.
So, is this not like a clear lie? A clear misrepres misrepresentation?
Can somebody somebody explain this to me? This is like a very
clear lie. No. Is this not a very clear lie? We just watched
why. Hey, it was it was late to file a tiro. I They weren't even
denying the relief. They're not saying, "Hey, they actually I
don't even know if they commented on his public comments." I
don't think anybody raised any objection to that. Am I crazy?
Like this is just a clear and open lie. But I guess most people
won't read through the documents. Most most people won't care
to know that this is just obviously not true. Like where where
in here did we find um public to get out of the public space.
There's literally they literally didn't mention that whatsoever.
That's why it was denied. And also the full motion wasn't denied.
They literally said that seems like appropriate relief. I'll
set I'll set a hearing for another judge. Null Envy, hop on the
Discord, bro. Hop on the Discord. Come and make your argument
in the Discord. Okay. You have a strong opinion.
You have a very strong opinion. I want you to hop on the Discord.
I want you not to be a tiny testicled little [__]
Hop on the Discord. Okay. Well, man, it's fun watching Pixie
lawsuit get getting slowly destroyed. Let's see if these lawyers
are pro bono as they claim to be when it gets dismissed. Nobody
claimed they were pro bono. They never claimed to be pro bono.
You actually do have low IQ. Crazy. What do you mean? Oh, by
the way, destroyed. The the null and v guy discord.gg/jok. If
you hop in the waiting room, if you hop in to argue your points
that you're making in in the chat on the stream, you get unbanned
from the chat. Okay? Automatic. Automatic Discord or ban, my
friend. Discord or ban. We run the relevant system here. Is Discord
or ban? We want to see you in the chat. Okay. Sorry, in the VC.
Hop in. Don't be afraid. Don't be scared. Come and make your
points. Come and come and argue your points. Let's go. Let's
go. Wait, did I get somebody joining? I did not. I thought I
I thought I just saw someone join. Okay. All right. I mean, I
think that's it. There was one other thing. It was like a letter
between them. Let me go Let me see if we can find that uncort
listener real quick. I wonder if that guy will end up joining.
Call yourself a debate. Well, you know, Destiny's fans are famous
for having no balls. Very famous for having no balls. I would
love I would just love them to hop in. Don't be scared, bro.
Don't be scared. Please. Why? Why won't you Why won't you come
and argue? Argue your points, bro. argue your points, bro. Anyway,
sorry. I need to take two seconds. Uh,
Kenny, go. Sorry. I'm just I'm just going to play this one more
time. I'll be right back. Video everyone losing their mind that
Destiny threatened to somebody cuz the I have like three communities
on that are obsessively upote, down voting, all my um people
are I think I don't even remember this phone call. This was like
months ago, but somebody basically asked me, I think Willy Mack
asked me something like what do you think about change lawyers?
If you're somebody that is actively engaged in a community that
is like spam linking revenge of me, revenge uh docs of me, docs
of my girlfriend, revenge porn, like if you're doing all this,
I super don't give a what happens to you if anything or whatever.
I think that was basically the gist of the question. And these
guys who are all kind of like
um they have no audiences for each going to be the next like
15 hours of streams for all these people. Um because they're
like so desperately clinging on to anything they talk about relating
to me. Yeah, he's gonna get you if you don't stop. Latched on
to this is like I'm trying to get them or something. Always score
an ethnoger. Why am I playing a map guessing game? Not saying
stock market doesn't matter. But I'm not a map guy. I would rather
like memorize countries and capitals. How could we latch on to
that saying he's trying to get me when all he said was
when all he said was like that's I do want somebody to logistical
though or laugh or Mr. for all. Wow. I wonder. Wait, how how
could we possibly pretend that he's trying to get anyone? How
could we possibly pretend that he might want somebody? The better
one is before that when it's like he's clearly trying to dox
both me and Queman. He's made multiple attempts. Okay. Multiple
attempts. And then it's like, oh, did I try to dox for Anna?
That's or just like Queen if I could. I choke the house into
it. Um, but not for Anna. No, to dox her is what you're saying.
Yeah. No. What the [__] Like why would I even want
to do that? Like what am I want? What? Like that's Why would
I dox Why would I dox Santa? What do I want? Somebody to kill
her or something, dude. It's amazing. Are you actually in fear
for your life? Probably not. Not from Destiny. Certainly not
from Destiny. But like it's still it's still horrible, isn't
it? Isn't it like isn't this literally like the bedrock of all
like free speech is that you shouldn't be threatened like with
your safety for saying things like And by the way, Odashar is
like openly schizophrenic for just one example. He's got a lot
of viewers who are like openly schizophrenic. That'sing that's
very weird. But also, I didn't think he'd try to dox me from
his own account with his own name. So, like I'm already I'm already
having my expectations blown away day by day as we go on. Okay.
Did we get this guy join the Discord or was he afraid? All right.
I think he joined. Oh, no balls, dude. None of these people have
balls, man. I I'd like I'd talk to any of them and they just
don't Nobody ever has balls. How we have so many people with
no balls who come and post in the chat.
Crazy. Crazy. Odashara is a fat loser. I mean, he's definitely
a loser 100%. Uh, he's also fat, but I just want to focus on
the loser part. Doesn't he? I I think he wasn't he in the Discord.
I remember him telling this story about how like he's got a trust
fund. That's why he's like lazy as why he's always in Discord.
Okay. He has a trust fund and so he pretends to be conservative
around his grandparents because they're going to give him money.
So like he totally he totally swallows like all of his opinions
and is like a neoliberal and then he's like yeah know I totally
I love Trump guys. I love Trump. Grandpa and grandma is very
funny. Like doesn't that make you feel weird? No. No. Is this
a guy? Waiting room. Oh waiting room. Who's this?
I don't know who this is but they're here. We'll just pull him
in. Naj, what's up? Who are you? How are you? Welcome to the
stream. Hi, I watch a lot of your content. Well, I haven't been,
but I like some of your content. Thanks. Thank you. Some of the
stuff I be seeing, but yeah, I I just got banned and I don't
know why I got banned. Wait, who are you? Wait, who are uh I
think
Okay, that's Yes, that is just you hop on the stream and you
just defend the things you're saying. So, I don't know what you're
saying precisely, but I got to pull up the logs. Hold on, give
me a second. Yeah. Uh,
we'll get you through this. This is over. You'll get back to
the mainstream. Uh, when you look at this now, it's not as bad
as what was presented. Okay. What do you think was presented
and how is this not as bad? Um, I thought like when I saw the
whole thing about the Pixie thing, I was like, "Oh, uh, like
he groomed a whole bunch of people and like um he's just like
targeting all these women because they're mentally ill or something."
Who said he groomed a bunch of women? No, that's what he he he
his daughter. Yeah. Well, I'm wondering where that came Um, I
thought it was implied in the thing that like he Pixie was groomed
by him. So Pixie Pixie implied that she trusted him. I would
say groomed groomed only in that she trusted him to have proper
respect considering consent and boundaries. Yeah. So like because
of his morals, which I think pretty much everybody would agree
they were groomed in some way by Destiny to think he believes
about or he cares about women's consent. Right. That's a little
bit of a stretch, but I'll I'll take it. I'll take that. Yeah.
Sure. like you you were you were convinced by his content and
by his statements by his professed positions that he probably
respected the consent of women in a single sense right I mean
I I still think he does but yeah why
what do you mean why why do you think he respects women's consent
in natures or actually why do you think he respects women's why
do you think he respects anybody's consent actually I mean I
think he it just benefits himself to respect other people's consent
and I'm just sorry I yeah go ahead I just from all of the violations
on the record. I would just be curious why you'd believe that.
What about all the good things as well? Like how many women does
he talk to that like don't like speak up and be like, "Oh, like
he's abusing me or whatever." Like there's like isn't there like
a he like so many people like how many people have come out or
am I What am I Are thereations as a part of this saying that
he abused somebody? What do you mean? Are there allegations as
a part of this saying he abused somebody? Abused somebody? Are
they? I not that I know of. So I'm just curious where that came
from. Okay. gota I don't know what it is. I don't know how you
talk. I you some DJers are same as you. You just said I'll just
run you I'll just run you through what you just said. You just
said um I just don't believe that he like abuses women. If he
abused women, if he like tried to rape women, then obviously
he has with a bunch of women. So like think about all the women
he hasn't raped, right? Then that shows he has respect for consent.
And I'm saying probably the time he does, but I think in this
circumstance for this situation, he didn't. Or I don't think
it I don't think it it's as malicious as a lot of people were
saying it is, but I do think it's bad. And I do think um he definitely
um Sure. So there are three instances that I know of at minimum
of him recording audio encounters. uh pretty clearly not having
the the consent of the other person. Recording with a hidden
device, which is Do you think What do you think that is? There's
two uh grinder encounters and there's a cherry stuff. A grinder
encounter. Uh how do you know it was
Uh because you hear him walking up with his phone in his pocket
before he meets the person and then it's like, "Hey, hi." And
they don't he never says, "Hey, I'm recording in my pocket."
So, uh, to my mind, if he had sent messages, if they had discussed
beforehand, uh, hey, I'm going to record my phone in my pocket,
they would have there would be records of that. Yes. Do you know
how Grinder works? Have you ever been on Grinder? I have not.
Okay. So, I'm gay and when I use Grinder, if I ever redownload
the app or like sometimes like if I was haven't talked to somebody
for some time that it's just immediately erased. So, I don't
know how you get those loss. So, if you were planning to share
those recordings with other people, do you think you'd make an
archive of that? Especially as the guy who archives all of his
conversations. The consent. Yes. No, I don't. For Grinder. Not
for Grinder. Oh, gay dudes. Gay dudes are supering promiscuous.
I agree with you. Gay people, they are operate on a totally different
set of rules. I mean, I'm not a good example of that. I wouldn't
really agree with that, but um you just said it. Did I? For gay
people. Yeah. I'm just saying I'm just saying that you don't
Well, no. I'm just saying. Okay, that's a little bad. I'm just
saying that. Okay,
hold on. What did Sorry. Do you just tell me what you meant by
by like for gay people? Yeah, I maybe I read it wrong. So, when
you said for gay people Yeah. What did you mean? I apologize.
For gay people. Did I say that? My June's getting
um listen
for Grinder. All I'm saying is that for Grinder, you can't really
get the logs back. So, I don't know how he archive the logs unless
he would later on know that he he'd keep it later so that he
could show it to people. I just don't understand why he'd keep
that to show to people that it was like consensual. So, your
argument here has to be he records with his phone in his pocket
before ever meeting up with the person. He puts his phone in
his pocket with it recording and then he meets up with them.
He records it. He has their consent to record, but he never pulls
the phone out of his pocket to get better audio. Right. And his
his claim there is like, "Oh, they're scared about the camera."
Even though the camera turns on, even though you could put the
phone in a way that like the camera's not facing anything, you
could cover the phone slightly but not cover the audio devices,
right? You could get actually good recording, but he never pulls
the phone out of his pocket. Is this not suspicious? Why would
you record all of these hookups with your phone only in your
pocket? Um, I don't know, dude. I don't I have no idea why. But
the thing is that is there someone coming out saying that like
that was like uh Cherry is Yeah. is saying that one of the recordings
with the phone's clearly in his pocket is him non-conensually
logs. Is there any logs of of like someone talking to her about
it? Like is there any logs talking about the situation? What's
the log? Like what do you mean logs talking about the situation?
Say that again. Yeah. Like logs her talking about what has happened
to her like what's going on? Like she did a whole Twitter post,
right? She did a whole Twitter post saying where was the logs
of her talking to about her talking to Destiny? I never saw like
the logs of that. Uh, I don't know. Why would we need logs of
her talking to Destiny when her argument is there's an absent
of consent there, right? Why Why are you asking her to prove
a negative? But we need to prove she's arguing that there is
no consent. Proving proving a negative. Okay. She has to prove
she has to prove that he did this. I don't know. We have to We
have to see it. We haven't seen anything yet. That's my problem.
Oh, the the audio was sent to her by multiple other women who
got it from Destiny and have said they gotten it from Destiny.
Okay. Okay. Is there logs? So, recorded without Yes. Uh, recorded
without consent. Shared without consent. No. Well, it's just
I mean, I guess it's just her word against him. I I Sorry. I
I believe somebody would come out and say it. I think there's
there's probably a way for me to get this and to send it to you
or to to prove it. But like, okay, we could just argue from a
hypothetical place, but there are like obviously I have logs
of this, right, of people. It's just hard for me to believe Cherry.
It's really hard for me to believe Cherry after like Oh my god.
After Okay, that was Mr. Oh my god. So, okay, you can say all
of that. She filed the police report. There's evidence of the
police report. The police took the police report. They didn't
just dismiss it. Okay. But beyond that, um there are multiple
women who received this audio recording. Okay. And uh this audio
recording has Yeah, I I'm probably not supposed to talk about
this case so much, so I might have to move on from this. But
basically like it's just I don't know how to explain this to
you. It's there's no question that this has been sent to multiple
people. Okay, you saying that. But let me just tell you something.
I have no idea. You can tell me all you want. Like the thing
is is that with Destiny, I can't really be like, oh, like I I
don't know a good example, but I'm just saying I can't I can't
take that from just like, oh, this is this happened. I'd have
to see I have to see what happened. I'd have to see evidence.
Oh, wait. So Naj, so what you're saying here is um what's your
point exactly that um Destiny's um in general good with women
and this pixie thing was a slip up? No, I just think he's a complete
gener. He's a he has problems and he has issues that need here.
I'll go in a I'll go in a different direction with regards Oh,
sorry. You finish, Kenny. Oh, so your comment was like JTO's
going to look back at this and regret it. That was your comment,
right? Or something like that. No. Did I say that? No. What was
his comment?
Uh, I don't think I would have banned him for that one. I've
seen a lot of people say that. That's kind of dumb. He just said,
"Oh, he's going back to the mainstream and like, oh, the lawyers
are cooked and it's over and so I was just like, oh, I think
that's totally incorrect." Yep. So, I was like, "Oh, come on
stream." I just hope when when people disagree, they'll just
come on stream and argue and then we can have a conversation.
Yeah. I Yeah. And I'm not that smart. I'm pretty dumb, actually.
You know, I never went to college. I, you know, I had a trade.
You don't need to say all this. Um, it's too bad. If we if we
had argued this before, I I have like I had proof, but I basically
I'm not supposed to talk about this anymore, so I'm going to
move on from this one. I can't argue this. Uh things just changed
recently. So, okay. Um let me ask you, let me ask you really
quickly. Um, when Destiny leaked Lauren Southern's son's name
to the 19-year-old Discord kitten, who he doesn't know the name
of, has never seen uh, like over a video call, has never met
in real life, when he leaked that closely guarded secret that
Lauren Southern has gone to great lengths to keep off of the
internet, thereby publicizing her child's son's name, do you
think that was bad? Do you think there's like do you think there
was something beyond being a gooner that might have been going
on there that like the whole internet knows that his name is
Didn't your mom try to like Destiny claimed to love her, right?
But he leaked all of her DMs, including her son's identity, to
this 19-year-old Discord kitten and is now the reason that that
information is public. Do you think that's because he's a gooner?
Cuz he's a gooner. No, I think he I think he just doesn't care.
Probably.
Yeah. Yeah, like he just doesn't really have concern or attachment
to like other human beings, even one he claims to love. He claimed
that he was in love with her, like deeply in love with her at
this point. He does, but it's probably different, I guess. Wait,
what was the context of why he he uh leaked that? He was leaking
all of his final relationship. Lauren Southern was breaking up
with him and he was leaking all of these DMs from Lauren Southern
to the 19-year-old for relationship advice. The 19-year-old worker
who he bought feet picss from. Yeah, he sent the DMs to multiple
people actually. Why do you say all those details? Uh because
it's supposed to make it sound more absurd that he would expect
these things to stay private. Okay. Wait, if anything like Well,
how long how long were they talking for at that point? I don't
think very long. Yeah, he must have been going through it. I
don't know what he was doing. Yeah, I'm I guess
what I'm I'm just saying. I'm not def I'm not defending all of
his actions. I'm pretty sure like what do you call I'm pretty
sure
uh I think my stance on it is that it's been two years whatever
happens at the court happens in the court then afterwards you
know but but that's you understand that's just a copout right
that all of this is like public information you can look at all
of it like it's just a copout saying it was 2 years ago you're
not actually engaging with the behavior you're just saying I
don't want to think about it was a long time ago it will just
be bad what happens in the court happens the court he dealt with
the damage I mean his career is kind
will have a hit after all of the accusations. Hopefully he can
salvage it and you know produce some great content.
Do you think I you know I like I like Pixie like yeah but like
I don't really care about her personally. Um I hope you know
if she can get some money after you know off this it would be
great. I think start with that instead of going through this
entire moral argument. You could have just started with that
and didn't need to have this whole drawn out discussion. I thought
it was Yeah. I don't know why I got banned first. I don't know
why you got banned either. I don't know. Exactly. Some I just
I just like having people on to argue with. Okay. Um also there
are three women he did this to without consent, right? Sharing
the videos of without consent that are public. There's two more
at least that he also shared just uh recorded uh consensually
shared non-consensually which are uh there's still Jane Does
as far as I know. You can treat it as a hypothetical, but I'm
just saying given that given that there are this many people,
like are you aware of that and does that go into your thinking
at all that it like clearly was a persistent pattern that in
that continued up until basically 2025, like November 2024 at
minimum or Yeah, sorry. Uh
actually, no, hold on. November 2023. So long after he'd gotten
on Vive ads and stuff. Bro, I just missed I just missed getting
a Sajuani. Um, I mean like so you're saying the earliest 2025
he hasn't changed uh 2024 basically since with Wet Woman. Uh,
again it's uh it's Molina, Stasia, and Pixie are the three that
are known. There's one more that I don't know who's in some of
those videos that I assume didn't have uh that I assume didn't
have consent considering the other people in the videos didn't.
But but like if it's if it's like 8 10. The question is basically
is there a number of consent violations where you're like oh
this is actually like a really bad person that I don't want to
watch anymore or you basically like no matter how many times
he like violates as long as it's not physical physical penetration
there's no consent violation that would make me stop watching
this guy or respecting him respecting his work and respecting
him personally are different. I don't really know him personally
and I don't think I trust him personally but his career and what
he does and what his career is him right he is an influencer
his company is destiny his career is his moral positions and
his political arguments politics is downstream immorality how
do you separate the art from the artist when politics are clearly
downstream immorality and he will not uphold his own morality
Kanye so I don't know it's still because Kanye's because Kanye
do you still respect and love Kanye's songs about how Jews suck
and they control the And Hitler's based, you know, after Trump
kind of Jews, dude, you voted for him. I thought your name was
I mean, you're meing, but you're meing, but you're memeing, but
you understand that the the separating the art from the artist
thing, right? Okay, let me be real. Okay. Yes, it's bad. What
do you want me to say about it? It's bad. This guy's trolling.
I mean, you already got my position. Now I'm just going to troll
you, dog. I'm getting right now. I have no Suani. No, your your
position isn't No, you've just been memeing the whole time. You're
not giving actual positions. I me I me'd half I mean half away.
Okay. I mean I mean he doesn't care. He's he's not one of these
guys who carries strong moral position. He's going to watch Destiny
no matter what he does. I don't I don't think that that's going
to change. Yeah. Destiny is just Ethan Ralph and I understand
that. I think Destiny's Ethan Ralph too. It's based Ethan Ralph.
Jesus Christ. Yeah. Like a morally represent repres Yeah. reprehensible
human who is really funny. Um, that's what you like that if you
if you only cared about politics, you would just follow Pisco,
right? Pisco has way more inhibition control. Pisco has way more
inhibition control. He's way more intelligent. He's way harder
working. And he's just he's just overall better in every way.
In every moral sense, he is better. You just watch Pisco if you
cared about the politics. You want the politics and to talk about
rape and to tell people that they deserve to get. You want all
of those things included in it, which I get it. I like edgy stuff,
too. I love edgy stuff, too. But if you if you just wanted the
politics, you just follow Pisco, right? You're doing a monologue.
I want I just said I don't I said I just don't agree with just
saying someone. That's just crazy to me. I didn't say somebody.
I said telling somebody they deserve to get raped because they
were stupid or something. It's just a joke about the uh the like
the what do you call it? Child comments. I It's It's literally
just a joke. You're focusing way too much. Okay. The analogies
and the edgginess. You just want the edgginess. You like the
the comedy, right? It's not about you respect his work. That's
not what it is. Can I just tell you why I can't watch Pisco?
Can I tell you? Yeah, sure. I I I sleep. I sleep. Okay. I'm trying
to do some digital art. I'm trying to play some TFT and when
I listen to him, I literally lose my games. Okay. When I listen
to Destiny, so it's not it's not about respecting the work. Well,
of course I respect the work. I mean, what he does, I gain a
whole bunch of information and then I can look stuff up, which
I probably wasn't going to look up anyway. I mean, yeah. If you
I'm just telling you that if you were if you were going to do
that, if that was your real concern, if that was what you were
primarily there for, you'd be watching Pisco. He's smarter. Okay,
some works harder. There's pondering politics. There's There's
Brian. Here's what I'm saying. I listen to politics. He's never
Pisco is never going to have a case like this pop up because
he cares more about people and making his message heard than
uh than basically trying to get a 19-year-old to fly out, sorry,
possibly 17-year-old to fly out to to him, right? Pesco is never
going to be in that situation. He cares about the people. He
cares about his his pet issues, right? Cares about building his
career. And Destiny doesn't have that same thing. You think Destiny
is gonna have another situation pop up again? Yes. Really? Yeah,
of course. Wait, what? Wait, how could you possibly say that?
You understand? The first time he he uh posted non-consentual
images of people was like 15 years ago, right? Sorry. Uh 13 years
ago, wasn't that with uh that one his one of his girlfriends
and he was just really Yeah, that was really stupid. I don't
know why I did that. Wait, hold on. You finish that because I
don't think it is. But continue. Which one do you think it is?
Isn't it the one where was like um the reason why his pick got
leaked because um Oh, it is. Yeah, it was the I don't know if
he's girlfriend with this guy, but he had posted a bunch of like
pictures of her in uh group chat, right? You could definitely
like put those two together. You can put those two together and
it's like a long-standing history of doing something. And then
he finally got, you know, then he assaulted me Rose. Then he
assaulted me Rose and then he pushed people towards then he continued
to Anavar while they while he was like calling her a stalker.
Basically mixing those two situations. She would literally tell
him like why do you keep calling me a stalker? Please stop calling
me a stalker. And he'd say sh just let me rub your thighs and
legs sweetie. Just let me rub your your legs and feet okay which
again in and of itself pretty disgusting to do as somebody who
has you know I think it's uh OCD obviously. And then from there
it was the arc with what Keles was. Then then it was the arc
with Keles where he kept pushing people towards Kiwi Farms. You
wanted to fund Kiwi Farms. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Let's stop.
Wait, wait, wait, wait. You're You're talking a lot. I'm just
saying. You have a whole stream. Listen, you're being like, "Oh
yeah, she has OCD." Okay, you could just say Desi has ADHD and
that's why he's a gooner. That's so stupid. Those are both stupid
arguments. I don't know why you're saying that. Wait, he has
ADHD and he's a gooner. Are you Yeah, you're meing again. I'm
saying Yeah. No, I'm saying DJ cheaters make this dumbing excuse
where it's like, oh, he was a gooner is ADHD. No, that's stupid.
It's a stupid argument. That's just dumb. That's You can't excuse
that. Why Why are you saying I'm trolling? Are you listening
to me? You No, I wasn't listening to you. No, I wasn't listening
to you there. But in any case, yeah, I'm just going through all
these things like Right. Like that basically people are like,
"Oh, well, I think he's going to stop now." Why? Let me pop my
guy real quick. I don't know. I don't know why he would stop.
Why he would stop? Yeah, I he hasn't faced any consequences.
He's He's got like the same He's got basically the same YouTube
viewership, right? Didn't face any consequences. I mean, he lost
some, but I mean, as long as he, you know, wakes up on time,
we'll be there. Yeah, I he by the way, I said that as long as
he just streams, if he does like some drama and politics and
just streams playing video games, I said he would be fine. He
would never lose any viewers. And yeah, it was just true. But
anyway, I just don't see any reason why I don't see any reason
why the behavior would change when he's shown no remorse and
no no consideration towards change.
I mean, Dan said he was changing and he said, you know, and he
believed him. So, there you go. Yeah. Dan Dan basically said
yes. My alcoholic friend basically told me that they're done
drinking and then they asked me for 20 bucks so they could go
to the corner store and I just gave them that 20 bucks because
I believe them when they said they're done drinking. And actually,
I just picked them up off a DUI. But you know what? I believe
them this time. They're done drinking. It's like, "Oh, but he
didn't get charged with No, he didn't get charged with a DOI."
DUI. I It's like It's just been no consequences.
I I I mean like no consequences. Uh a lot of people now see him
as like past uh freak or whatever who, you know, grooms skits
and shares 15-year-old swimsuit pictures of people when that
wasn't really the case. But you could frame it like that, I guess.
But I mean, he did do it, but it's not as how people picture,
you know, people picture him as like a pile. I mean, he leaned
into it and said repeatedly, "The 15-year-old was super hot."
When asked about it later. What do you mean it wasn't like that?
But it was like the context that that was literally jailbait.
Yeah. But then when he was asked about it, he was like, "Yeah,
15-year-olds are hot these days or whatever, right?" He like
doubles down. Yes. Because some people are actually
Do you not understand that? You can take that position, but what
do you what do you mean that? Do Do you know what jailbait means?
Wait, I'm sorry. Blank says, "Ask him if you play Smash." I don't
play Smash. I play League. So, I'm Go ahead again. What? Uh,
wait. What do you think jailbait means? Um, does it mean like
it's like when someone's like underage, but they look, you know,
of age. You want to them? Because they're of age. No, they No,
because they look of age.
Why are you making this argument? She knew she was underage.
Yeah. Like he literally said, "Yes, she was hot." Like after
he knew the age. Yeah. Someone could still be hot. Has no one
watched Mr. Girl the Cuties thing? You could still be hot, but
sure. I'm You're saying don't pretend that he's not Don't pretend
that it's like something weird he's saying. I'm saying he is
weird. It is a weird thing to say. It is a weird thing to just
stand on.
Well, not stand out. It's supposed to be like you're supposed
to be talking about Okay. Wait. I don't understand. If someone
says you're a, you know, you're a or you do these things, you're
a creep or whatever, and you're like you're defending your actions
or whatever. and he just stated
what was the case. I don't see I don't see what was wrong with
that.
Ask him if he thinks Tristana or Lulu is hot right now. Bro,
Trist Oh my god,
I don't.
Yeah, but Oh, Varnish could totally hop in here, right? Tristana
was
Yeah, true. Mr. Girl. Oh my god. I swear to God, all these people
This guy can join right now. Uh, I just don't like hop in the
Discord. Okay. I don't like it when people are like, oh, like
a streamer did this and then it's like the streamer condones
this and it's just like or like he you watch people who condone
this [__] I just don't like it. Just be honest. Okay.
We don't like Destiny. Okay. He's a gunner. He did bad things
to people. What are you talking about? What are you saying? I'm
just saying with the Mr. Girl. What Mr. Girlit? um that he like
literally talked about somebody and then like also be wait one
second hold on wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait didn't
you just argue that nobody came forward over those recordings
those grinder recordings so we can't possibly say that was bad
okay so who came forward to charge Mr. Girl with rape Mr.
No, no charges filed. No charges filed. He beat the case. No.
No charges filed. He beat the case. Isn't that a valid argument?
We'll see how the court case plays out. No court case there.
Unless you're going to argue that when there's overwhelming evidence
in the public eye that we should take that and make a moral judgment
based on that. I'm going by his words. I'm going by Mr. Girl's
words. What do you mean? He literally said, "I this woman and
he explained how he did it." He and he explained how he did say
that. Uh I He might have explained. Sure. The same way he explained
how he explained how the same way he explained how the same way
the same way that we have the exact proof of all of Desty's problems,
right? No, I'm about to say that's what I'm about to say. I say
just like how Desty was like, "I'm sorry. It's my fault all this
happened because I shouldn't be flirting." That's the same thing,
bro. You act like I'm literally halfway on your side. I used
to watch you, okay? And I used to watch you until until you went
on the damn podcast or whatever. I was like, "I'm going to blackmail
you, Lma. I'm going to blackmail you. I have all this information.
But you you know what that was, right? That was because Destiny
wanted me to come on and argue with Dan about it because he didn't
want to have the argument himself. So, he sent me all of the
financial information about anything else. You know that, right?
Yeah. I don't know. I don't I just don't I just don't know why
you present. Okay. But N we could easily defeat your argument.
You understand that, right? Understand what? No, that that's
why that argument happened. Why the rift happened between me
and Dan? That's why me and Dan were cool after. I just literally
somebody trying to Okay, that's fine. But I'm just I'm trying
to explain to you that that was like Okay, I understand how you're
trying to defend it in your mind. I'm just saying people like
that. N can't we just say Mr. Girl, Jtock, and Destiny are all
bad at the same time? Doesn't that like defeat your entire like
When did I say Jessica's bad? You brought up blackmailing. You
think blackmailing is a good thing? Not really, but I don't think
a person's bad because they do a bad action. Also, just so we're
clear, I didn't I didn't actually blackmail him either. Uh I
said So I said it in a way that it seemed like blackmail. No,
no, hold on. Hold on. I said it in a way that because I was like
emotional about it. But hold on, hold on. I I want you to know
and Dan understood this uh that I told Dan I was going to do
like a whole uh post explaining where I got the financial information
from and just post all of it because he had basically lied and
said, "Oh, we're not making any money." And they were like $20,000
in the black already, right? Um and he didn't want that public,
so he didn't want me to post it. So he's like, "Please don't
post it. Please don't post it. I'll I'll help you out. I'll help
you out." Right? But I told him I was going to make all that
public. And so what I told him was basically or what I was trying
to tell him is hey I am going to just do what I said I was going
to do before. But it wasn't like it wasn't hey you have to do
this for me. It was like hey just so you know I'm going to do
this. This is me saying like hey I am going to go post that so
people understand why I argued with you cuz I was given all that
information to like argue with you. Like people basically your
podcast partner didn't want to do that podcast with you in the
like in a paid only setting. I'm sick. And I'm saying that's
a what aboutism and even if you did do something bad doesn't
change the fact Destiny did something bad. And even if Mr. all
did something bad doesn't change the fact that Destiny did something
bad. I could just say they're all bad and you're and not just
arguments like doesn't make any sense. Sure. I didn't know I
had to get toasted right now. Jesus Christ. I don't even know
what you just said. You mumbled your whole way through that.
I don't know. I don't know who is it. Can you just cook this
guy? Can you just cook this guy and he tried to say he didn't
hear it? Okay. No. No. I'm saying you did tons of what aboutisms.
Okay. They're all bad. Okay. It doesn't matter. It doesn't change
the fact that Destiny did something bad. Bro, I'm so glad I didn't
go to school because I don't know what the [__] you
mean by that. Holy. Oh, I feel so good being uneducated. It feels
good. This is why this is why you're bronze in TFT, bro. Yo,
stream. You're bronze. You're bronze. You want me to send it
to you right now? I'm
streaming to get masters. You stream my game right now game.
Let's commentate on this. You're going to meet the most game.
You're Oh, I'm the smartest black guy you ever seen. My skull
is huge. Okay. All the lies. Vanguard.
Uh, bro, you're in seventh place right now. Lose streak. Three.
Three lose streak. Are you serious? Yeah. It's not looking good
for you. Why are you quiet? You're in seventh place. I'm patient
study. I'm patient study.
Okay, buddy. I'm going to lose this game. I've been talking all
this [__] Yeah, that's what I thought. You thought
what? You're trash. What? Game. What? What's What's your What's
your rank? What's your rank, dog? What's your rank? Obviously,
I'm leaving. What's my rank? Of course. I'm the your emerald.
Yeah. One second. No way. Let me see here. I'm going to I'm just
for you. Just for you. Just for you. Just for you. Just for you.
Just for you. Okay. Yo, why you so pressed? Impressed. About
to just send you something. Oh god. Hey, buddy. You're pressed.
You're pressed. You lost. Yeah. Oh my god. Random stuff. Desktop.
Random stuff. Not my diamond. I mean, uh, aims for groin. No.
Uh, doxing is taking people's public information and coating
it for the purpose of harassment. I'm I'm saying it so that I
can point out that Destiny leaked his name, right? Cuz he doesn't
care about other people. So, he totallyed over all of Lauren's
efforts efforts to keep that private. I'm not doing I'm not doing
it to harass anybody. I'm not doing it to harass like Lauren
or a kid. Not at all. Just doing it to point out that Destiny
leaked it. What was the point of the text on screen? I believe
Destiny was watching the stream, so I just threw that up there
to annoy him. No, sorry you guys didn't see it. Okay. Uh, I think
we're getting one more guy on the stream possibly. Is this him?
Oh, it's Little Wubby. I don't want Little Wubby in here. He's
annoying. Really unfortunate Destiny leaked that. Well, I mean,
Destiny leaked it in a forum that was leaked like like I don't
know what, like millions of times. Been viewed millions of times.
Why would Destiny watch? I don't know. Apparently, he was watching.
Didn't she try to kill migrants on boats with a flare? Kind of
kind of feels like it's deserved, right? Okay, I'll just let
that hang there. You are good, I guess. I defend it. Okay. What's
that red name? XX trash man. He wanted to [__] He
want to talk.
What is this? Queen rated in. Okay. Based mean I need to tell
Naj
something. Uh I don't think so. Yogi. Who this? What's Queen?
What's up? Nice. We actually got some DJers coming to argue tonight.
It's good times. Wow. Awesome. Uh this guy's mostly just meing
though. I think he's been meing since the first like 20 minutes
or so. Wow. Wow. Unfortunate. Am I Am I I thought I I thought
I'm saying what I really feel, you know. Uhhuh. Okay. Anything
else? You want to say anything else in the stream, buddy? Um
I'm actually uh the last thing I'll say is that I'm a legendary
DJer. Actually, I was the one guy who tweeted at Keles
um about her getting
Yo, Gay, you're on the stream. What's up? He was the one guy
that tweeted at Keles. That's how we will remember him. Oh, I
need to unban him though. Hold on. Uh at no I came in here to
say something to Nash and he's already gone. Say say it right
now. Just say it right now. Is it Is it League of Legends advice?
Is it League of Legends advice? Cuz you'll be gone. Master is
not a flex. You're part of the circus. Oh god, these people are
so gross. Null and V is unbanned from the Discord though. Thank
you. Thank you. Or not Discord. Uh what do you call it? The Twitch
chat.